hi I'm Michael FINA hello I'm Ken and
Gillan and I'm Jack Black we're taking
the BuzzFeed Jumanji quiz to see which
avatar we really matches our personality
yeah and I'm very excited nervous all
right let's get started y'all so what
animal would you absolutely not want to
have on a one-on-one staring contest
we're not wanna have not want to have
and the options range from a snake tiger
spider bear shark and I fear nothing I'm
going shark come on that's the scariest
animal out of all of these I don't want
to come face-to-face with one cuz you
know you're about to die I chose a snake
a lot of times you see guys like
swimming with sharks and the Sharks just
leave them alone
the spiders like who cares it's a spider
and I hate spiders but they're gonna
leave you alone the bear will eat you
did you ever see that movie Grizzly Man
mm-hmm I'm gonna go bear when faced with
a conflict typically you run away as
fast as you can assess the situation
carefully before acting seek the advice
of someone wiser which is almost like
calling a home oh and call your friends
for help okay
9 times out of 10 you are the confidence
well I don't like conflict I'm not gonna
lie but I'm not so averse that I would
run away from it I do kind of just Mull
it over for a second and then I come
back and I deal with it and I'm deeply
uncomfortable during the whole thing
which is why I assess the situation
carefully before achtung assess the
situation carefully
my thing is usually just like a problem
that comes up I like to deal with it
right away I don't like to wait and so
I'm gonna say faced the ICU head-on
that's what I want to get to because it
Fester's in your mind if you don't just
deal with it and I would also also would
run run away oh I would run yeah not
fast which of the following foods would
be your in-game weakness is there an
option for all take pizza french bus
gandhi hamburgers bread just any kind of
bread hamburger mmm
oh I know what this is hands down let me
take our burger over a slice of pizza
over everything it's my favorite shame
it's so good you don't even want to call
it a sandwich
which classic arcade video game do you
like the best
pac-man Space Invaders centipede Frogger
Galaga and pong Frogger
he's a child a scrounge me I'm going
Space Invaders it makes me think of this
type of crisp in the UK called space
invaders are you just going off name for
those of you not from the UK they're
called chips the a potato chips crisps
go Galaga because that's the one where
it's like space invaders but it's an
upgrade where you can end up having like
two spaceships to shoot in double time
it's very satisfying Galaga which common
nightmare do you find yourself having
the most frequently hauling naked teeth
falling out they don't have the one
where you walk into class and it's
finals and you've never studied how come
they don't have that one I have one
where I can't remember my lines in a
scene that I didn't know I was supposed
to be shooting Wow but you know what I
get from time to time falling from a far
distance Wow I'm waking up right before
impact my grandma says that's when you
grow like when you fall asleep and you
like that that's you said that's when
you grow you like spurt
oh so it's a good thing it's interesting
it's a lie I have one where I'm in a
small plane and then I know that it's
crashing and I get the full feeling of
knowing that I'm about to die and then
as soon as there's impact to the ground
I wake up and it makes flying a little
more scary yeah but that's not on here
so I'm gonna save our distance I never
dreamed I was naked in public I always
kind of yearn for that dream you never
had that one never happen when you go to
school and all you have is a t-shirt and
you're pulling it down over your yeah
it's always the too short t-shirt it's
not even the right size yeah watch it
being fully naked because you're kind of
like trying to cool it down rather than
just being naked you just care so you
got to find a barrel like in the
cartoons and finally which color speaks
to your a-slash
vibe the most red purple blue green
orange or pink well I'm wearing orange
so I was gonna go orange orange I love
green but I think that's just because of
meet the parents
De Niro said it's the color of genius
and if I'm being honest I think it's
blue clicking bloop we're all like Jonas
hope you're having a good tour what does
that say it says you're savvy adaptable
and patient
it means the word Dreamboats yeah we're
dream boats with a lot of funds I mean
that's a really good one to be it means
we can sing like a mofo we dance like a
mofo
we have brothers we're a sucker for you
um I'm Priyanka loves us can we keep
these I'll sell it on the Internet all
right oh you guys walk off the mic is on
the chair y'all I'm a sucker for you
[Music]